So 111 Do you remember anything about Ditch 11 on the cloth
dit gh Hyphen 11
Come on,
you know it's a
game, right?
Did you do an online auction 16 years ago? You said you did, so that means
you're the
same person who defrauded me of 100,000 yen 16 years ago when I was in elementary school.
That's why I didn't know this from a while ago I'm in a
hurry Why did the discoverer let me check if your smartphone has power
?  I
'm sure I'll kill you.
Hey, normally wait a minute, I don't know, you were going up.
Don't worry if you haven't heard from me around that time I'm
sorry I lied It was you who defrauded me of 100,000 yen 16 years ago
[music]
My life is tight It's you
ana
fufu
large
ah ah ah ah ah
nan
ah ah ah
me
ah